douze ans après le lancement du projet
les premiers logements de la zac renard
à 100 sur l'école pourrait enfin voir le
jour des premières livraisons fin 2015
c'est en tout cas le souhait de la frt
de l'agencé foncière et technique de la
région parisienne propriétaires des
terrains de l'ancienne caserne depuis le
21 décembre dernier elle a déboursé 16,8
millions d'euros pour racheter des
terrains à l'état notre rôle c'est un
dash de terrain du celta d'aujourd'hui
deuxièmement c'est d'aménager le terrain
d'y amener dès voirie les réseaux
l'assainissement l'eau et c'est d'y
réaliser tout l'espace public
place espaces verts et autres et puis
c'est de revendre ensuite par l'eau à
des constructeurs promoteurs qui
viendront construire pour l'essentiel
des logements sur ce site à terme un
écoquartier de 1450 logement et ses
équipements publics la ville gardera un
contrôle sur la réalisation la mairie
elle a un gros troll qui découle de la
sq de concession d'aménagement
au c'ur à la fois le nombre de
d'appartements le nombre de maisons
individuelles le nombre d'accession à la
propriété et aussi sur les équipements
publics puisqu'il ya près de huit
millions d'équipements publics qui vont
être construits seulement du côté de
l'opposition estiment ne pas avoir
encore assez d'éléments la présentation
du projet n'étant prévu en conseil
municipal que le 15 janvier autre point
qui pose problème le coût trop élevé du
terrain pourrait entraîner un prix de
logements excessif pour la population à
saint cyr dans les logements sociaux il
ya plein de gens qui en fait sont au
dessus des vraies conditions pour être
dans le vent social mais ne peuvent pas
être dans le privé parce que le saut
financier trop important
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la ménagerie la
monter les prix ce qui veut dire que
tous logements dits intermédiaires on le
retrouve plus dans la zac quelque part
bernard de bain on peut dire moi je
contrôle la situation en réalité il
vient de laisser perdre une occasion de
créer un type de logement qui nous
manque dans vie 10 ans seront
nécessaires pour la réalisation complète
de ce nouveau quartier mais avant que
les premières bétonneuse n'arrive une
dernière dépollution industrielle est
prévue en 2013